[Music]
so rachel these people just got married
made good morning america oh yes with a
500
wedding
and her wedding dress was 47
and i thought
i will give you the applause
well and especially if you don't have
the money right like that's the point
their goal was they didn't want to go
into debt good morning america did a
full
uh feature on them the other day and uh
abc news our friends up there
um
uh this couple uh kyrah and joel broken
bro bro brawl okay
bro bro broken bro i guess it is john
um we're able to pull everything off for
just 500
uh in los angeles which is way less than
the nearly 30 000 national average
uh for a wedding
and um
their goal was just to be as minimal as
possible kyra said uh and to spend the
least amount of money possible the bride
and groom said they were able to do that
by putting a heavy focus on not going
into debt while starting their marriage
way to go guys
that's our people right there i like you
yeah so
uh she apparently bought the dress
online for 47 and i thought it was going
to be when i was reading this and looked
at the article i thought it was going to
be one of those um
uh deals
i don't know consignment there's a thing
where the like the prom dresses and
stuff and all that yeah yeah that you
can
that's a but that's a rental thing isn't
it yeah i mean there's there's all kinds
of things but hers was a legit beautiful
white
dress that yeah she just found a deal on
it yeah yeah
and it's probably honestly was not
called a wedding dress like it was a
long i saw the picture as beautiful just
a long white very elegant looking dress
but
when they put like um well cocktail is
short oh i'm sorry it was it was a
full-length gown it wasn't i will i will
educate you on that but uh no but i
watched the clip too and
and she
a lot of their family helped with
certain things so like the her aunt did
the flowers
uh her sister had a beautiful
like runner for the aisle and they got
married i thought this was great the
venue was free because it was literally
on the side of the road in l.a so like
one of those pull-offs that you pull off
pull-offs on the side it's a huge look
in the ocean yeah it was beautiful and
it was a and they i guess they just
pacific island and everyone just parked
right there and they got white chairs
right down so she probably ran out of
the chair it's probably part of the 500
budget uh the fine from the highway
patrol was 2 000 but the wedding was
500.
i don't know but they did it i was like
this is brilliant like it was great and
it was beautiful too because she said
she was like listen it's our wedding we
didn't want to go into debt for it and
this is what we had one day it's one day
and it's and it's to show and bear
witness to the fact that we are giving
vows to each other to
be before god before god and a lifelong
commitment and the people there and so
the guests paid for their own food and
drink at the reception
and she said they didn't mind because
they knew what they were doing she was
like they don't want to sign up you did
that because not because you were cheap
but because you're trying to stay out of
debt or get out of debt or something 100
you told me uh i i would i would
definitely pick up my food and drink at
the reception as a guest and i will pick
up somebody else's yep you know i just
think it's so cool and uh you know i
mean there might have been some little
uh
i don't know some little niche or
something that didn't think it was cool
but i bet all the old people loved it oh
absolutely and again it's because there
it there's a greater why for it all
right they they didn't go into so
anyways it was awesome so great gosh so
great versus there was a story actually
was on good morning america about two
years ago to do a segment on weddings
and it was like they covered this one
wedding and it was like photo booths and
fondue fat all of the stuff which is not
bad and i i want to say that you can
have a great big wedding if you can pay
for it but they were taking out a
personal loan
for the expenses of their wedding right
so we did a whole segment on it but i'm
like that
versus this
so polar opposite and
and there's just there's there's such a
beauty in that contentment piece that i
think is just awesome so
very cool we've had big weddings in the
ramsey family you and your sister your
brother we just love big parties and we
love big celebrations and and so we've
enjoyed
that but we could afford to write
whatever check that was it wasn't
completely unreasonable you gave us a
budget but um we did give you a budget
um it was a nice budget but it was a
budget all right
um so but but just the same i mean this
is
uh
i i'm thinking of other people on our
team here who have gotten married lots
of them for under ten thousand dollars
lots of under 10 000 weddings um
and here's the thing it's one day
i mean if you said i'm gonna go out to
eat
and spend 30 000
you would shoot i mean you go no
no because it's one day i'm gonna go on
a one-day vacation
you know i'm going to this place and
we're going to stay one night and one
day and the cost is ten thousand dollars
or thirty thousand dollars you would be
going what but that's essentially what a
wedding i mean it's a one day thing or
two day thing with a rehearsal dinner
but you know oh my gosh
yeah so uh it's okay to do it you just
need to have the money but uh we've
created this um
expectation almost of what it should be
yeah it's just crazy it's almost created
by the by the businesses around it too
the diamond industry
the uh that uh i don't know who
but we've romanticized an america
weddings uh in india and america the
weddings are both just over the top
but most other cultures they're not and
so i just love this i think it's so
mature
and uh they're really married before god
she said and uh and before they're
friends and they're they they're gonna
have a great life it's awesome um and i
just way to go hats off from the ramses
so guys pretty incredible the ramsey
team here brought this to us and said we
wanted to salute you guys you know what
i told daniel my brother when he got
married i was like listen take the
wedding budget
cut it in half
use the half for the wedding and use the
other half for marriage counseling all
years down the road because working on
your marriage
is a whole lot
has a lot more value
than the day it really does so yeah
that's uh he didn't do it but yeah you
know neither did you but no i didn't
so i had that advice after
i was like
yeah it's easy it's easy to tell other
people after you're done right
i love it all right we're going to talk
to you about your life and your money so
by the way the average household income
in america is around sixty thousand
average budget for a wedding is around
thirty thousand so people often ask us
about a wedding uh that means the
average is people spend half of a year's
income that's the average now do you
this is a case where you'd want to be
below average um but if you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year if you
spend more than 50 you're out of control
and for wedding engagement rings
uh your rule of thumb is like one month
one month's income max jewelry store
tell you three but they're in the
jewelry sales business so keep that in
mind
one month max
and there is no correlation between the
size of the diamond and the uh
how long the marriage lasts
as a matter of fact there may be an
inverse correlation this is the ramsay
shot